Hey entomological magnetometers, Matt here
for a DNews Short.
A new study was released in February of 2017,
where researchers magnetized dead and living
cockroaches.
They exposed the cockroaches to a magnetic
field about 100 times stronger than a fridge
magnet (1.5 kiloGauss, for you EM nerds out
there), for 20 minutes.
Afterward, they checked to see how long the
insects remained magnetized: 50 hours for
dead cockroaches, but only 50 minutes for
living ones!
As it turns out: cockroaches, like birds,
bees, dolphins and a host of other animals
and bacteria can detect Earth’s magnetic
field.
We know this because researchers have tested
cockroaches in rotating magnetic fields, and
used radio waves to successfully block possible
magnetoreception -- their sense of Earth’s
magnetic field.
Nature evolved a number of ways for animals
to sense the magnetic fields.
Some animals, like honey bees, have little
granules of iron in their abdomen -- they
literally have a gut feeling about where to
go!
Whereas others, like sharks and some birds,
have what’s called radical-pair sensors,
essentially a chemical reaction creates a
charged molecule that acts like a compass.
The researchers who did this experiment, think,
because the decay of the magnetic field happened
so much faster for the living cockroaches,
they must be using a living chemical reaction
to keep the magnetoreception going, i.e. they
have a radical-pair sense.
A better understanding of how this system
works could teach us about other animals that
are more difficult to get into a lab like
sharks, birds or even people!
That’s right, humans might have this sense
too, but researchers couldn’t get repeatability
in their experiments -- yet.
In the end, if we can figure out this roach
magnetoreception, it could help engineers
design better micro-robots, and sensors!
All thanks to our little friend, the cockroach.
But like, I know they’re cool and weird
and stuff… but why do cockroaches even exist?
What are they for?
What do they do?!
Find out in this video.
Do you have the best sense of direction?
Or none at all?
Let us know in the comments, subscribe, and
come back for more DNews.